das gibt uns die Gelegenheit für ein
weiteres Gespräch Alice Weidel ist bei
uns Co-Vorsitzende der afd-fraktion hier
im Deutschen Bundestag guten Morgen gut
dass sie Zeit gut dass sie Zeit für uns
haben Angela Merkel haben sie definitiv
nicht gewählt das wissen wir in den bei
der letzten Wahl Olaf Scholz haben Sie
vermutlich auch nicht gewählt oder na
natürlich habe ich ein Scholz nicht
gewählt aber Merkel ist weg
ja so kann man das nicht sagen also
durch die neue Ampel werden die Dinge ja
nicht unbedingt besser sondern eher
schlechter das ist meine Sicht der Dinge
dass ich die Dinge vor allen Dingen auch
in Sachen corona-maßnahmen verschärfen
werden hat die Ampel ja schon gezeigt im
September wurde noch von Herrn Scholz
und von Herrn Lindner versprochen die
Impfpflicht nicht einzuführen auch nicht
für einzelne Berufsgruppen genau das
sehen wir jetzt das ist ein klarer Bruch
des Wahlversprechens ein epochaler
Wortbruch so habe ich es gestern
bezeichnet und das werden sich die
Wähler natürlich genau merken aber die
Lage hat sich verändert die Lage hat
sich verschärft wir haben jetzt eine
neue Variante
dieses Virus dieses Omicron die ormicon
Variante die sich sehr viel schneller
verbreitet und die damit auch
gefährlicher ist müssen wir vor diesem
Hintergrund nicht sagen in gewisser
Weise ist es nur schlüssig dass ich auch
die Maßnahmen ändern müssen wissen Sie
bei dem ganzen
Variantenreichtum den wir hier seit
Monaten hören also nach Alpha kommt
Delta dann Omikron und vom Alpha zum
Omega und jede Variante ist gefährlich
ich habe es ja selbst gehabt Corona ich
gelte jetzt nun als genesen und da muss
ich ihn ganz ehrlich sagen vom
Krankheitsverlauf her ist das absolut
richtig dass jede einzelne Person für
sich entscheiden kann ob sie die Risiken
er Nebenwirkungen oder eines Verlaufs
für sich persönlich einschätzt und ich
halte einen Impfzwang für
kontraproduktiv und wenn sie jetzt in
einzelne Berufsgruppen hineingehen
Pflegekräfte wir hatten schon vor Corona
hatten wir Pflegenotstand und ich
prophezeihe Ihnen dass sich dieser
Pflegenotstand noch verschärfen wird
durch diese Maßnahmen sie treten den
Menschen den Pflegekräften wir zwei
Jahre lang die Menschen aufopferungsvoll
gepflegt haben die nicht geimpft sind
treten sie ins Kreuz und das hätte die
Politik nicht tun dürfen in anderen
Ländern in Europa um uns rum wo das
schon länger der Fall gewesen ist ist
dieser Effekt nicht eingetreten also die
Leute haben nicht in scharende diesen
Bereich verlassen also sondern wir haben
dann unterm Strich Impfpflicht nicht den
Impfzwang haben die impfpflichtern
akzeptiert auch um sich selber sicherer
zu fühlen nämlich mal an gut die sind ja
überall in Europa in den Städten auf die
Straßen gegangen die ganzen
Berufsgruppen also so einfach ist das
nicht gesagt und vor allen Dingen müssen
Sie die Leute einfach mal machen lassen
sie müssen sie vernünftig bezahlen und
Sie müssen wir vernünftige
Arbeitsbedingungen Sorgen das ist ja
schon seit Jahren nicht der Fall und wie
kann man in einer Krisenzeit wie dieser
Intensivbetten eigentlich noch abbauen
also da ist die Impfpflicht der völlig
falsche Weg ich glaube dass wir deutlich
mehr Wettbewerb am Impfstoffmarkt
brauchen wir können lediglich zwischen
mrna-impfstoffen und Vektor im Stoffen
entscheiden warum denn nicht zwischen
Proteinen und Tod Impfstoffen das ist
doch das was die Menschen bewegt und das
bleibt es doch einfach mal abzuwarten
und es ist geboten Wettbewerber
Konkurrenten für andere Impfstoffe nicht
aus dem Markt Moment hinauszuhalten
sondern eben auch zuzulassen jetzt habe
ich gerade morgen im Radio gehört das
gerade die Mischung verschiedener
Impfstoffe genau das ideale ist um sich
vor Corona zu haben
nur Vektor
und Stoffe und Protein und todimpfstoffe
stehen noch aus
gehindert weiter zu forschen und wir
sobald die ein Produkt haben
t-
es ist falsch
sie klingen sich diese Impfstoffe impfen
zu lassen es ist falsch sie müssen
entscheiden ob sie sich mit
proteinimpfstoffen mit Tod im Stoffen
mrna-impfstoffen oder Vektor im Stoffen
impfen lassen nur die letzteren die ich
gerade aufgezählt habe sind bisher am
Markt es bleibt abzuwarten welche
Impfstoffe noch an den Markt kommen und
dieser Freiheit muss man dem Menschen
überlassen das kriegen sie nicht durch
eine Impfpflicht hin ja aber die da sind
die sind ja zugelassen die sind ja
geprüft und irgendwie alle die geimpft
sind also es gibt ja das Risiko durch
das Impfen ist ja im Grunde nicht
vorhanden wenn man sich die aktuellen
Zahlen anguckt deswegen verstehe ich
jetzt die Problematik nicht die sie da
aufmachen weil ich sie nämlich
eigentlich fragen wollte habe ich sie
jetzt richtig verstanden dass sie nicht
deswegen
Stellen
ganz kurze kleine Frage ich möchte von
Ihnen einfach nur wissen sie will mir
keine Antwort geben ganz kurz noch
natürlich möchte ich Ihnen antworten
machen wir es doch ganz einfach
ich bin normalerweise nicht so klein ich
nein ich habe sie nicht unterbrochen
bitte stellen Sie die Frage danke ich
wollte einfach wissen habe ich Sie
richtig verstanden dass sie nicht
generell gegens impfen sind oder wo ist
da der Punkt bei ihnen ich habe sie
einfach nicht verstanden sind sie Gegend
dass die Menschen sich impfen lassen
generell gegen das Impfen ich bin für
die impffreiheit die Menschen müssen
auswählen können und da haben wir viel
zu wenig Wettbewerb am Markt das bleibt
es abzuwarten die noch an dem Markt
kommen müssen und die Proteine im Stoffe
weil die Skepsis ist erst entstanden
weil neuartige Vektor und mrnr
Impfstoffe in der corona-krise verwandt
werden die vorher am Menschen noch keine
Testung hat nur noch nicht verwandt
worden das muss an den Menschen
zugestehen ich wollte doch nur wissen ob
ihr sie richtig verstanden habe mehr
wollte ich doch eigentlich gar nichts
auf der einen Seite aber sagen die
Menschen sollen selbstständig überlegen
ob sie sich impfen lassen wollen oder
nicht sollen auswählen können da können
sie doch auswählen im Moment da fehlt
doch nichts das habe ich aber auch schon
mal gesagt sie können nur zwischen
neuartigen Impfstoffen und mRNA im
Stoffen entscheiden und die anderen
kommen Vektor bzw Protein und
totempfstoffe kommen Ende des Jahres bzw
im ersten Quartal 2022 das sollte man
doch einfach mal völlig unaufgeregt
abwarten tun wir ja sowieso immer nur
abgewartet weil es werden Bußgelder für
eine Impfpflicht werden die kommen und
sie können die Menschen so nicht zur
Impfung zwingen es ist kontraproduktiv
und die Skepsis ist ja auch begründet
sagen sie das muss man den Leuten
einfach zugestehen dass sie selbst für
sich entscheiden sich impfen zu lassen
oder nicht ich lasse mir das auch nicht
von irgendwelchen ahnungslosen
Politikern sagen sie
Ehrenamt 12 märz haben sie getwittert
Dänemark Tschechien Italien weitere
EU-Länder reagieren sie stellen das
öffentliche Leben praktisch ein nur in
Deutschland kann sich kovic 19
ungehindert ausbreiten das wird fatale
Folgen haben die Regierung muss jetzt
endlich angemessene Schritte einleit
Hashtag corona-deutschland was wären
denn heute wo sie ja gegen weitere
Beschränkungen sind wie wir in den
vergangenen Wochen gehört haben was
wären denn heute aus ihrer Sicht die
angemessenen Schritte also ich muss
sagen dass mir auch diese Position im
Zeitstrahl absolut Recht gegeben hat ich
habe dafür plädiert präventiv tätig zu
sein Schutzausrüstung für
Schutzausrüstung zu sorgen
Desinfektionsmittel schutzmaßen damals
als man noch nicht wusste wie gefährlich
dieses Virus ist dass sich ja
ungehindert ausbreiten konnte und hätte
die Bundesregierung früher gehandelt und
hätte nicht noch erst im März gesagt als
ich das geschrieben habe das
Händewaschen reicht und dann drei Wochen
später die komplette Schubumkehr mit
einem total Lockdown dieses Landes ohne
Präventivmaßnahmen ohne
massenausstattung darum wird es ja
gesagt die Bundesregierung war überhaupt
nicht vorbereitet und das
Bundesministerium für Gesundheit hat
einfach geschlafen und es hat ja das
ganze Jahr dadurch geschlafen weil er
mich genau die Risikogruppen in den
Altersheim und in Pflegeheimen wo
beeinträchtigt gewesen sondern man hat
einfach nicht gehandelt man hat
geschlafen was würde ich heute sagen
genau das gleiche wie damals man muss
auf die bürgerliche Eigenverantwortung
setzen vorsichtig zu sein sich impfen zu
lassen wenn man das gerne möchte wenn
man die Auswahl an Impfstoffen hat und
nicht die Menschen zu zwingen mit
Bußgeldern und sonstigen Berufsverboten
halte ich für einen völlig falschen Weg
aber funktioniert ja nicht sonst hätten
wir diese Zahlen im Moment nicht wieder
am Impfstoff mag nicht haben wir haben
keinen Wettbewerb sie haben
monopolistische Strukturen und das ist
völlig falsch und darum sind die Leute
skeptisch bei Konkurrenten ganz gezielt
aus dem Markt rausgehalten werden aber
wenn ich doch eine Auswahl habe auf dem
Markt sind wir keine nochmal nein sie
haben nur eine Auswahl zwischen Vektor
und mRNA Impfstoffe sie haben kein eben
aber die Auswahl ist nicht weitreichend
genug nein es fehlen die Totimpfstoffe
und deswegen fehlen die Proteine im
Stoffe das sage ich aber jetzt schon zum
zehnten Mal ja und ich bleibe aber weil
das die Auswahl ja da ist und man kann
sich ja entscheiden wegen
nicht
natürlich
krank
aber in den Krankenhäusern sind
überwiegend umgeimpfte auf den
Intensivstationen natürlich stimmt das
sind überwiegend natürlich stimmen die
Zahlen wo haben sie ihre her nein stimmt
nicht wo haben Sie denn ihre her ja
schauen Sie sich die staties an
Bundesamt für Statistik sagen Sie jetzt
sagen Sie es doch wissen Sie was
Interviewer deswegen ja aber sie
konfrontieren mich mir völlig falschen
Zahlen ich habe gar keine Zahl genannt
ich sage nur dass die unter der belasse
ich mich auf die Dinge
noch irgendwie überein ich bin natürlich
nicht weil ich natürlich nicht weil ich
mich beziehe auf die intensivmediz
und die Pathologen was sagen die sagen
Ihnen schon mal was ganz anderes warum
werden eigentlich die gesamten Toten
nicht obduziert warum lernen wir nicht
mehr über die Todesursachen warum wird
das nicht gemacht wir haben hier noch
ein wissensproblem und dieses
wissensproblem wird nicht angegangen
auch das ist ein Fehler der Politik und
auch der Wissenschaft und Leute die da
sehr sehr kritisch sind Wissenschaftler
Pathologen Professoren die werden auch
plötzlich als wirköpfe Spinner
hingestellt wenn Sie eine abweichende
Meinung haben so geht es natürlich auch
nicht ich bin nicht sicher ob wir das
tatsächlich ein wissensproblem haben ich
glaube wenn es Klarheit über die
corona-lage gibt dann ist hier relativ
deutlich muss ich ehrlich sagen jetzt
müssen sie selber ein wenig schmunzeln
wissen Sie eigentlich wollte ich dieses
Gespräch
führen eigentlich wollte ich dieses
Gespräch anfangen mit welche
Schwerpunkte will die afd-fraktion
eigentlich in dieser 20 Wahlperiode des
Deutschen Bundestages setzen dann haben
sie meiner ersten doch noch etwas
offenen Frage irgendwie gleich aufs
impfen rekoriert deswegen kommen wir da
jetzt gar nicht mehr zu es sei denn sie
bei mir in zwei drei Sätzen doch noch
sagen
Olaf schalten
nein das Briefing war völlig korrekt das
Problem ist nur als ich mit einer
offenen Frage angefangen habe sind sie
sofort aus
impfen gegangen und dann muss sie
natürlich darauf eingehen wenn Sie die
Antworten immer die gleichen Fragen
gestellt obwohl wir schon längst
geantwortet haben
ihre Fragen sind
da würde ich sagen steht es eins zu eins
und ich stelle Ihnen noch eine
abschließende Frage zum
zukünftigen Bundeskanzler wie sie das
einschätzen und auch wie sie das neue
Kabinett einschätzen und was sie von der
Ampelkoalition erwarten also ich warte
ich erwarte natürlich überhaupt nicht
hier von der Ampelkoalition wenn sie in
den Koalitionsvertrag reinschauen sehen
Sie nicht eine einzige Lösung für die
Probleme in diesem Land ist sie haben
gar keine Strategie was die
Energiepolitik anbelangt was die
Außenpolitik anbelangt was die
dringenden Probleme auch innenpolitische
anbelangt wo sind sie dieser
Koalitionsvertrag wurde nur geschmiedet
und drei verschiedene Parteien mit einer
knappen Mehrheit über Wasser zu halten
vielen Dank dass Sie heute morgen bei
uns gewesen sind das waren wir hoch
spannend dieses Gespräch und deswegen
schauen wir wie es im Plenarsaal ausgeht
um uns ein wenig abzukühlen und deswegen
machen Katharina kühn und Nico Friedrich
jetzt weiter